hey youtubers is Charlie so ten for some
more Doctor Who since the Time Lords are
trying to break into the regular
universe I wanted to float a theory to
you the fact that we will see more Time
Lords in series eight or series nine
this totally opens the door for people
that might not make the best doctor but
would make excellent Time Lords so let's
talk about who those people could be in
addition I'll also be talking about my
choices for potential new companions too
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video we don't know quite how long Jenna
Louise Coleman is going to stay on she
hasn't signed up for series 9 yet one of
the row beauties of this is that a Time
Lord could totally just be a quick cameo
so we can think of actors that might be
too busy to say be on this show all the
time cue the fanfiction here are my top
10 picks for who those people could be
number 10 Andrew Scott he's been the
quintessential villain at Sherlock
series 1 but his portrayal of Moriarty
has this playfulness that feels just
like a madman in a box there were even
some Sherlock actors that guest-starred
on Matt Smith's run like Rupert graves
as much fun as it would be to see him
become Doctor Who's greatest nemesis the
master I feel like it would be too
obvious of a choice so giving Scott the
opportunity to channel some of his crazy
performance into a good character would
be a nice change of pace and he would
still totally have all of time and space
to cause mischief in number 9 Tom Hardy
as the warrior the existence of the war
doctor is totally proof that Time Lords
can be warriors so wouldn't it be fun to
see the very large you know physically
imposing Tom Hardy play a Time Lord it
was still in a warrior incarnation of
himself just because you're a warrior
doesn't mean you have to be a villain
the doctors code never cruel or cowardly
is something that's unique to him not
all Time Lords have to have laid down
their swords after the time war ended so
I'd really like to see Peter Capaldi
meet another warrior Time Lord and try
to get him to chill out Hardy could also
just be like a physically big you know
imposing doctor just like Eccleston's to
number 8 Jude Law the Pretty Boy Time
Lord I'm totally just joking with the
Pretty Boy but for a lot of his career
that's what Jew law was known as the
pretty boy I think he'd do an amazing
job of playing up post-gender swaps Time
Lord during doctor's wife Matt Smith
even alluded to the fact that he had a
relationship with another Time Lord that
went from female to male julik could
totally play that character or someone
like him even though father implied that
all those messenger cubes belonged to
Time Lords that he had killed number 7
Ralph Fiennes as the new Rassilon
Timothy Dalton was amazing as Rassilon
during Russell T Davies run but because
the tone of
show has changed so much since the 10th
doctor and you know we'll continue to
get darker
I think Lord Voldemort would bring the
right level of intensity to the ruler of
the Time Lords there have been a lot of
theories about where Rassilon was during
the events of the 50th anniversary and
confusion over whether or not he's still
trapped in that time lock bubble but for
the purposes of this video
you know let's assume that he's on
Gallifrey with all the other citizens
right now so vote YES for Lord Voldemort
Rassilon number 6 Dame Helen Mirren as
the woman in white so many theories
about her being the doctor's mother but
let's assume she's not for a moment just
so we can open the doors to making her a
good foil for River Song also rumoured
to return in series 8 who would ever be
able to out River Song River Song but
the Queen of England she's such an
amazing actress she could play almost
any of the characters on the show like
say a female master but making her the
new woman in white would just be a good
pairing for an episode or future
anniversary special but that also
featured my you know Rassilon dream pick
Ralph fine note that you don't have to
have both those characters in the same
story whenever you bring them back it's
just the last time they appeared the
woman in white and Rassilon worked
together
number 5 Wendell and Christy as Romana
pre 50th anniversary her status was
alive / unknown in some of the non TV
series material she even took Rassilon
job as president for a brief period
regardless of previous portrayals of the
character as Brienne on Game of Thrones
Gwendolyn is one of the most positive
and powerful women in science fiction
and fantasy superpowers notwithstanding
the woman in white is another really
powerful female Time Lord but I always
view that character being played by an
older actress Vermont on the other hand
seems like it would be a better choice
for a younger actress Gwendolyn would be
about three inches taller than Capaldi
so it would make for some great visual
gags - as in you are a wise mentor to me
but I am probably going to be the one to
pull your ass out of the time fire at
some point number four Hugh Laurie as
the meddling monk think Black Adder
Jeeves and Wooster Hugh Laurie not house
Hugh Laurie we spent so much time
watching him play a character that
resembled the war doctor it would be so
much more fun to watch Laurie go back to
his comedy roots and play a Loki type
Time Lord he's not evil he just likes to
make a mess of things who better to
clean them up than the stern twelfth
doctor just picture Capaldi giving
Laurie the stare number three Ben
Whishaw
as the scholar I don't really see him
playing the same type of Time Lord as a
hulking Tom Hardy but Ben Whishaw
was one of my top picks for the twelfth
doctor before Peter Capaldi was
announced
imagine an amalgam of his characters
from James Bond in the hollow crown I'd
really like to see him as a bookish Time
Lord who Capaldi would go to for
assistance with some unsolvable riddle
picture his TARDIS is looking like a
more grand version of the library we saw
during series 7 number 2 Tom Hiddleston
starting to break into the realm of
fanfiction but this is a wish list so
Hiddleston even co-starred with Whishaw
in hollow crown he's been this
consummate bad guy ever since Thor but I
think that he has the perfect level of
ambiguity that would really lend itself
to being a Time Lord the doctor always
said that the time war twisted his
people so imagine the scene in Avengers
where Loki steps out of the portal for
the first time looking all haunted and
deranged but not totally evil just
imagine a Time Lord burdened with
glorious purpose mewling Quinn's for the
win and my number one pick for a new
Time Lord she was hell IG for the
rumored almost 12th doctor she Mattel
was supposedly the Anglo African actor
offered the role of the doctor but then
turned it down for personal reasons this
is all based on conjecture from a
statement Neil Gaiman made but it's
since passed into fanfic legend if he
was good enough to play the doctor and
he's probably going to win a Best Actor
Oscar just think of what he would bring
to a Time Lord character so in related
news there is a ton of other actors that
I had to leave off the list
Idris Elba Eddie Redmayne Aidan Turner
and Benedict Cumberbatch but we have to
set a few aside for potential choices
for a new master so if there's anything
that I really hope to see in series 8
it's a new Time Lord like a new major
character not when we have to say all
the time but someone really powerful
like Rassilon or even River Song based
on a lot of comments that the production
staff is making people are assuming that
a lot of classic who's coming back but I
really hope that Moffat introduces some
new things into the Canon now it's your
turn though let me know who would you
like to see play a new Time Lord in
series 8 or series 9 remember this is a
wish list it could be anybody you want
male/female old young so unless we get
any other really big news from the set
my next Doctor Who video is gonna be my
top 10 choices for a new companion you
know either in replacement of or in
addition to Jenna Louise Coleman be sure
to subscribe to get it
we don't know quite how long she's gonna
stay on she hasn't announced anything
about series 9 yet right now click here
to learn more about series 8 and click
here to get my Sherlock series 4
predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you